so again we're building this foundation
of poi fou and I'm making the first few
weeks I'm making videos they're gonna
overlap between the beginners course and
then beyond the basics course so the
beyond the basics course I just expect
you to go a little further with it but
we want to practice the basic modes so
we can practice again we can imagine
this is a person or a wall if it's a
person it's Chris it's if it's a wall
it's just a wall so if you have a friend
to play with you can try this again it's
always if you look this way this hand is
touching if you look this way this hand
is touching
don't touch both hands you'll get
confused so if this hand is open we can
circle towards now we hope the cranes
over there
so you circle towards the cranes yeah as
we turn if we get every time we keep
going back to this key position yeah so
if they go we're in it then we're
turning and Marina's we keep passing
through that position while we're in the
teeth that's where if we want we can
switch hands and we're what is that
building the museum I think where we're
going the old museum
so we're circling away from museum and
if we turn were circling towards the
cranes Oh away from museum towards the
cranes await the museum towards the
cranes away from museum towards the
crates now if you only have a wall
behind your wall if this is a wall not a
person same idea but the wall is not
moving so if I go like this my left hand
is touching the wall I swim towards the
cranes when I got here I switch and now
my right hand touching the wall I swim
away from the museum what I don't want
to do is touch both hands in the wall
because they don't go like this right so
you really need to make the choice
either my left hands touching the wall
or my right hand touching the wall left
hand right hand never both there's and
that's just for now because if you're
doing butterfly like then both will be
touching the wall right or maybe you
want to do something like this right for
wall playing flowers you will do this so
it's not a rule it's just an exercise
but same thing you want to open they get
to the point where you're going towards
the crane away from museum towards the
crane away the museum
if the crane steth museum crane museum
train museum I think I know what you
want to think about it's your posture
your spine is tall your head is tall
your hearts open your shoulders are
relaxed your hips are turning your feet
are light in the ground so you're not
putting pressure on your knees or your
ankles it sounds like you're relaxed
relaxed relaxed I'm never doing this
with my shoulder
I'm turning enough that my shoulder can
be dropped right if I don't turn it'll
look like this and that's going to blow
my shoulder out so you want to take your
time and make sure you're relaxed bounce
I can get bounce a bit mix you sit
relaxed you can wobble my hands is it
relaxed does it relax and as I know it's
relaxed I can start to speed up so if
you're in the beginner course you can
just really get the basics of this if
you're feeling good if you're gonna be
on the basis of course you can really
let it flow more yeah and then we'll
start adding point to it soon thank you
you're welcome
and the next and then it's another video
it's going to show where to go with this
next